tatsächlich gibt es aktuell nur eine
partei die den verbrennungsmotor
insgesamt bis 2030 abschaffen will
die grünen und das ist ganz schön mutig
denn für viele deutsche ist ja der suv
das einzige familienmitglied für das die
echte gefühle aufbringen können ich weiß
wovon ich rede
wir schalten mal wir schalten mal leicht
zur bundesgeschäftsstelle in berlin zu
dörte hausten geschiedene knalligen
dingeldey von dem kreuzberger grünen
dörte dümpelt ihre partei vielleicht
deswegen in den umfragen nur noch bei
sieben oder acht prozent rom ja sorry
aber mit dem verbrennungsmotor hat
meiner ansicht nach herzlich wenig zu
tun dass wir als partei so abgeschmiert
sind der tat natürlich ganz anderen
grund und ich denke sie wissen was ich
meine
nein leider nicht dann will ich auch gar
nicht lange um den heißen dinkel brei
herum reden von unserem letzten
parteitags im bilde rausgegangen
die dürfen sich so nicht wiederholen
ganz schlimme bilder
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz schlimm furchtbar
ja da werden mich meine enkel fragen
roma dörte wo warst du als die göring
eckardt getanzt hat warum hast du dich
nicht dazwischen geworfen die haube
kommen leicht vom thema ab sorte
benziner abschaffen finde ich ja ok aber
wie soll das bis 2030 praktisch klappen
mit den ganzen e-autos david auch bei
uns durchaus unterschiedliche positionen
der winfried zum beispiel der ist ja
nicht happy über die deadline ja da lief
neulich bei mir sprechen der kamera mit
und wenn man ja nun orten an land schon
seine leichte unzufriedenheit bei ihm
inzwischen das mit in ruhe lasst mich in
ruhe
[Applaus]
dpa
ja die haben dann seine medikamente um
ihr stellt und dann jüngst auf wieder
alles locker und na klar jetzt hier und
da noch diverse ich sach mal problemchen
im autobereich für die batterien zum
beispiel brauchst kobalt wird im kongo
von kinder arbeitern aus dem boden
gekratzt
es ist furchtbar keine frage aber ich
hab gehört die kongolesischen kantinen
sind überwiegend vegan und rissen
pluspunkt ja da ist eben vieles leider
noch nicht zu ende gedacht wer in
deutschland stromtank der tank heute vor
allem braunkohle in unsere netze sind
gar nicht so viele autos ausgelegt dass
man wenn ich mal meinen fetten tesla
lade und nebenan fühlt sich noch einer
geht das licht aus
ja ist nicht gut für meine haare
wahnsinnig brüchig aber das betrifft
sicher ähnlicher welpe war ne im ernst
mehr an stop nur orte oder benziner
wir müssen weg vom verdammten
individualverkehr bus bahn oder
wenigstens eine fahrgemeinschaft also
das mache ich doch schon jetzt für jeden
morgen zusammen mit einem anderen
berufstätigen man nach köln rhein jeden
morgen du musst auch immer zu meiner
firma ich weiß gar nicht was du da
machst
ihr chauffeur herr welke macht mich alle
so traurig ja jetzt will ich immer was
sagen es wird der tag kommen da werden
auch sie morgens schön in den elektrobus
sitzen weil nämlich eine standard mehr
fahren nach in der stadt
und dann werden sie froh sein weil er zu
wunderbar leise ist und zwar so leise
dass sie
[Applaus]